ce serait nul s'il est là-dedans en
train de faire une overdose
et
je vais être partout pendant un
moment
avez-vous pris quarante dollars pour moi non mais
j'ai trouvé les 20 sur le chemin ici
où avez-vous trouvé ceux qu'il leur a apportés
et nous  Je vais les brûler,
mon plan de sauvegarde est
fier de
toi mon visage sur notre chemin six jours le sixième jour
demain marque la semaine
ouais je préfère me faire du mal que du
mal  souviens-toi vraiment de l'avoir appelée,
mais apparemment, la conversation était un
peu comme ton maire, je ne serai pas en vie
trop longtemps si je reste ici comme la
façon dont je vis n'est pas bien, je tire toujours de l'
héroïne et de la méthamphétamine tous les
jours,
il  m'a appelé comme au milieu de la
nuit en braillant les yeux je pouvais dire
qu'il était vraiment foutu vraiment déprimé
vraiment bas et il était comme mary comme
il était comme si je n'allais pas y arriver il est
comme si je devais sortir de cette ville  si je
reste ici je vais mourir je le sais je
sens que j'ai besoin que tu viennes  et comprends-moi, j'étais
comme d'accord, je t'ai eu comme
bien sûr et cette même nuit, il a pris tellement
de drogues que j'en ai une vidéo parce que
j'étais comme toi, je documente cela,
j'ai littéralement comme si j'allais quelque part et
je suis sorti  et je viens de le voir
s'évanouir sur les marches
[Musique]
je faisais juste une overdose et je n'aimais pas
le regard sur le visage de ma mère quand
elle avait le narcan moi
j'ai narcan quelques personnes et euh
vu ça de première main et  puis voir ma
mère me voir traverser ça, c'est comme oh
merde comme si c'était ton enfant, tu sais ce que
je veux dire comme
avec des lèvres violettes comme des lèvres violettes bâillonnant tout
ce genre de trucs effrayants et je
ne veux plus faire subir ça à ma famille
[  Musique]
la quantité de honte et de culpabilité qui
s'accumule est [ __ ] de folle, comme si je m'en occupais toujours,
mais
je ne me défonce pas en ce moment,
je n'ai vraiment même pas la possibilité de
me défoncer dessus en ce moment
ne sont pas dans mon
sac à outils en ce moment les cigarettes sont bien
et
restent ici o  ut of trouble is
définitivement the goal
wood all around
[Music]
elle se réveille
vers huit ou neuf heures je me réveille
vers la même heure elle est
probablement ici en train de faire une réunion pour un travail ou
pour les trucs cryptographiques ou Internet ou
le  pour un moi plus jeune ou quelque chose comme
ça
et je me promène en
essayant d'éviter ces petits démons dans
ma tête
avant même de venir ici, j'ai
accepté comme si tu montais
là-haut, tu n'aurais qu'à
cliquer  avec ta sœur et fais ce qu'elle
fait parce
qu'elle a manifestement plus compris que moi
aujourd'hui,
nous comptons tout, tout est
documenté
est beaucoup plus gentil que moi je ne suis pas une
bonne personne tu es une bonne personne tu es
une très bonne personne des gens qui te raconteront
beaucoup d'histoires différentes mais dans ton
cœur à toi ouais autour de toi et à toi
oui bien sûr
non tu es une bonne personne
tu as mal agi  ngs mais tu es une bonne
personne
je ne pense pas que cela ait un sens
tu as fait de l'action
ouais exactement non tu es une bonne personne tu
ne peux pas changer d'avis à ce sujet
tu viens de le faire
tu as l'air plus doux qu'eux  c'était l'
année dernière donc tu as l'air moins parce que j'ai
finalement dormi
[Musique]
et j'étais l'un de ces enfants j'étais comme
seulement mec de l'herbe et de l'alcool je pense que tout
ce dont tu as besoin de rien d'autre rien de plus
tout le reste est le diable
et euh
est tombé d'un longboard  à 16 ans et est tombé dans le
coma pendant quelques mois
quand je suis sorti, j'avais une perte de mémoire à court terme
et on m'a prescrit des
analgésiques par le cul
et en plus comme les médicaments 80d adderall
et les médicaments contre l'anxiété et le xanax donc il
était juste en train de m'éplucher vraiment
quand je suis sorti du coma ma
grand-mère était décédée mes parents avaient
divorcé et donc je suis sorti de
l'hôpital comme d'une certaine manière sans abri
et ensuite nourri de médicaments
il est passé de prendre des
pilules tous les jours en vendant des pilules  pour
obtenir de la dope pour vendre de la drogue
et ensuite mélanger  de la drogue ou de la coke et puis
c'est juste une chose quotidienne et vous commencez à
perdre des veines et vous commencez à perdre de l'argent
et cette poupée qu'un sac a transformée
en quatre et quatre à huit en un petit pain en
deux petits pains en une brique en une manche
et puis c'est  tout simplement incontrôlable quand
tu te fais arrêter et que tu es
stupide pour gagner de l'argent en regardant quelqu'un que tu
aimes plus que tout choisir une
substance comme l'héroïne tu vois la lumière
quitter leurs yeux j'aime passer des
nuits comme attendre cet appel téléphonique
comme toi  ton frère est mort
parce que tu sais que je t'ai vu j'ai vu ses
lésions cérébrales j'ai vu son accident comme si
j'étais là à l'hôpital j'étais là dans
les mots psychiques j'étais là comme si j'avais dormi
dans la chambre avec toi tant de fois et
l'un des
accords que je me suis fait à un très
jeune âge était mary tu as besoin d'obtenir une
éducation dont tu as besoin pour [ __ ] le camp
de cette maison et ne jamais revenir et je
voulais m'assurer que je n'avais jamais besoin ou
besoin de compter  sur n'importe qui ian 100
respe  Cité qu'en ce moment, nous sommes ensemble
parce que je peux financièrement me permettre
tout ce que nous faisons, c'est pourquoi
cela va être si réussi, nous sommes une
équipe ensemble, nous nous élevons tout
le temps,
alors comment se sent Ian après le
jour quatre
yeux  j'ai l'impression que vous allez tous les deux éclater
ma langue j'ai l'impression qu'il
n'y a pas de malédiction
comment sont vos premiers jours c'est affreux j'étais
partout
c'est des sueurs froides des
frissons étreignant les toilettes
euh ne dormant pas ne mangeant
vous juste décomposez et diminuez lentement
et tu vas te sentir
mal à l'aise pendant quelques jours mais
tu ne vas pas être
follement malade de la drogue brutale donc c'est un
peu ce que j'ai fait
quel jour sommes-nous sobres six jours le sixième jour
demain marque la une semaine
ouais
nous sommes le septième jour
Nous sommes au septième jour
se sentir bien tu as
ri tous les jours
tu as dormi  encore une fois
eh bien je préférerais avoir un certain type de
confort comme un type de
pas
anxieux et secoué et bizarre je
n'aime pas ça pas mon truc
[Rires]
Ian m'a dit de le rencontrer ici il a
marché toute la journée
il ferait mieux d'être ici  en ce moment j'ai
un peu l'impression qu'il n'est pas
là
et
j'espère que je me trompe et j'espère qu'il est là
j'espère qu'il va bien
mais d'
accord je voulais juste partager
je ne le vois pas
ce serait nul s'il est là
surdosage cependant mais j'ai du narcan dans
la voiture alors peut-être que je vais prendre ça et puis
repartir
mais non je n'ai entendu personne
j'ai pris du verre comme arme le
temps de trouver la fin
je conduisais à ta recherche d'
accord
je sais pourquoi tu ne montes pas dans la voiture et tu ne
reviens pas
parce que j'ai des avions est-ce que tu as tiré
non tu ne peux même pas acheter des aiguilles ici
ou est-ce que j'ai de l'argent
tu as l'air un peu foutu en ce moment
ouais j'ai bu  j'ai trouvé une bouteille
sur le bord de la route c'était une jolie
pochette
ça coulait mais
bon je suppose que je vais  garer et passer du temps
avec toi et tes amis
pourquoi pas j'irais chercher de la nourriture et je
t'appellerai quand j'aurai fini de faire ce que je fais
pourquoi ne reviens-tu pas simplement
parce que j'ai des
plans pour obtenir des emplois  posé
je pense que tu devrais revenir avec moi
tout de suite
je sais ce que tu penses
t'appeler
plus tard le jour 14
a été fou
je suis fatigué
[Musique]
je comprends c'est dur pour les deux parties et
c'est dur pour quelqu'un qui ne comprend pas la
dépendance  aider quelqu'un qui
est un toxicomane qui a arrêté tous ses médicaments psychologiques
et tout ce genre de choses pour
maintenir l'équilibre quotidien
et la façon dont cela l'affecte me fait mal
parce que je ne veux pas mettre ce genre de
négativité sur qui que ce soit.  plutôt
me blesser que de la blesser en
bref
je suis un coureur je suppose que selon
mes petites cures de désintoxication et mes services psychiatriques comme
quand de
gros problèmes surgissent je pars juste comme
cool comme quoi que ce soit si je suis un problème comme
je partirai comme ça
ça ne me fait pas de
mal et ça vous sera probablement bénéfique
donc
c'est un gagnant-gagnant
[Music]
ia  n explique
qu'il ne croit pas que je comprends
ce qu'il ressent je veux dire que les gens vont
dire oh tu n'es pas sobre oh tu as bu tout ce que
tu fumes oh tu as fait des sous-marins ce n'est pas
propre ce n'est pas propre
Je ne vole pas ta je
ne vole pas ta maison avec une aiguille
dans le cou donc
je pense que c'est un progrès mais tu ne
veux pas le faire cette fois
tu es différent cette fois tu es dans un
environnement différent
ça ne marche pas  s'en aller dans 10 jours je sais que ça
ne s'en va pas ça prend au moins six
mois on va
poster des retraits aigus ensemble en
parler comme si c'était bien tous les jours
même si j'ai l'impression que la chanson est
condescendante je te condescendance
oh  je me penche
il y a des croquettes il y a des jouets il y a des
bols et la nourriture humide les choses importantes
oh les bébés
je ne veux pas qu'ian ait l'impression de prendre
soin de lui parce que je ne suis pas comme
honnêtement je traîne juste avec  mon
frère parce que je l'aime et je veux
m'assurer qu'il va bien parce que je
sais qu'il est plus p  owerful que sa
dépendance et j'ai pensé que ce serait bien
pour nous d'aimer avoir quelque chose d'autre à se
soucier dans le processus je dis que
nous aurions dû avoir un chiot pas des chats l'
ouvrir
paix amour unité respect clair
comment vous vous sentez
bien
j'attends toujours le  pire que je ne
m'attends pas à de bonnes choses parce que c'est rare et que de
mauvaises choses arrivent tout le temps, donc je m'attends juste à
ce que
l'autre chaussure tombe n'importe quel
jour, donc quand elle tombe, ce n'est pas
trop un
choc, je vais faire quelque chose de stupide c'est
inévitable donc
je pense que jusqu'à ce que cela se produise, pourquoi ne pas essayer d'aider quelqu'un que j'aime même si
c'est juste pour lui permettre d'avoir la
gratification de penser qu'il
m'aide comme ça c'est cool avec moi
je pense que nous en sommes à ce point je pense que
notre équipe est  assez fort pour aimer commencer à
faire avancer les choses nous travaillons sur un
mouvement appelé pour les plus jeunes mai l'
idée est que feriez-vous pour aider la
jeune génération je
commencerais personnellement par la crise des opioïdes
donne moi une seconde
michael pensez-vous euh nous  'serai  capable d'
entrer en contact avec nick gomez ou euh
crypto picasso parce qu'ils ont créé une
pièce et ils ont également créé une
application ça va être une idée
qui est ouais
plutôt cool d'accord donc il
nous reste six minutes mon frère juste
je dois aller le trouver  il est juste
sorti merci les gars je vous parlerai
bientôt
je ne pense pas que quelqu'un aimerait quand
quelqu'un vous prend de l'argent
et je ne pense pas que ce soit euh vous savez comme
je suis là pour lui j'investis beaucoup  de temps
et d'énergie en lui et la sécurité et
la sobriété et vous savez que
mes objectifs et mes aspirations sont
ma priorité à la fin de la journée comme
même en les aidant c'est donc c'est
comme quand
je prends du temps pour moi comme ça
c'est  comme tu sais j'aime tu sais que
j'aime mon équipe comme je veux aussi les
soutenir et ce qu'ils
font et leur donner toute mon
attention
avez-vous pris quarante dollars pour moi non mais
j'ai trouvé les 20 sur le chemin  voilà
c'est ce que je fais
avec ton interview avec ton ticket
ok
alors moi et ian nous sommes disputés et il a
décidé qu'il allait y aller
ian
bonjour
et c'est vraiment
cool mec
j'allais partir hier soir
faire mes bagages prendre ma
nourriture
quand j'étais dehors oh notre première chemise
devenait haute à coup sûr
à coup sûr  c'était le moteur comme cette
merde dont je n'ai pas besoin je vais aller bien
et c'est que j'ai ma merde j'ai ce dont
j'ai besoin
je vais vendre des trucs voler des trucs
voler un concessionnaire je m'en fiche
mais alors  je dormirais dehors dans le
froid et la pluie et probablement
affamé demain peut-être malade dans une semaine la
stresser stresser les autres je
suppose que
c'est comme un mec à double personnalité ça
craint c'est comme si c'était littéralement comme une
dépendance à double personnalité est réel
et  les frères et sœurs sont réels comme si nous nous étions disputés la
nuit dernière, tu sais,
mais nous y sommes de retour le jour 21 et je suis
content que tu sois de retour et je suis content que tu sois
monté dans la voiture avec moi tu sais quand
tu '
je veux dire je ne sais même pas si j'avais
ouais je n'étais pas sûr que tu les
obtiendrais soit
tu veux  jeter ces aiguilles dans
mon sac ouais tu veux le faire
euh
non je ne veux pas le faire tu me laisses le faire
sûr
qu'il a fait un sac la nuit dernière quand il
partait
devrais-je les enterrer
devrions-nous en faire une fleur
les casser tu les casser
je ne sais même pas comment fonctionnent les aiguilles mec
qu'est-ce que je fais
une fois je dormais et euh il
s'est évanoui et comme
s'il était vraiment foutu une nuit et j'étais
comme
tu sais qu'il n'y a que  tellement de choses que vous pouviez
faire quand quelqu'un était comme ça, alors j'étais comme si je
me détendais à côté d'eux comme si
j'essayais de
me dissuader de ce
cycle de dépression et il y avait tellement d'aiguilles dans
le lit qu'il y en avait tellement
et comme l'une d'entre elles presque comme poignardée
moi aussi
tu veux faire un câlin
non
oh
21 jours on va avoir ça ici yay
[Musique]
je ne blâme jamais le toxicomane pour sa
dépendance
j'ai vu ça quand quelqu'un est
accro à l'héroïne les gens lui ont dit qu'il était
junkie  Toute sa vie, notre père l'
appelle un junkie, notre mère n'est-elle pas
une  ngel alors il est euh bouleversé par ce qui
s'est passé la nuit dernière et il a mis une
cigarette sur son bras
il était comme si je l'avais fait il était comme si
je ne referais plus jamais ça j'étais comme ian
tu n'as rien fait de mal comme ton
expérience est normale  comme si c'était bon
tu vas bien ouais c'était vraiment
comme si
tu savais que c'était juste quelqu'un qui
essayait vraiment de se changer et
ne savait pas comment tu sais
bien sûr que je vais constamment
penser à des façons de  déchirer et courir ou vous
savez faire quelque chose de stupide ou se défoncer ou se
saouler mais je sais
que quand j'ai eu du temps propre comme
il y
avait certainement des moments incroyables que
je ne
remplacerais pas cela par se défoncer
et vous savez que votre famille recommence à
vous aimer c'est
les
gens cool ne cachent pas leurs portefeuilles ou
leurs portefeuilles devant vous
ils ne sont pas
comme
frapper à la porte de la salle de bain pour s'assurer
que vous êtes en vie et
vous savez vérifier votre pouls quand vous
dormez je ne sais pas
si je devrais  compter mes bénédictions plus que moi
ne faites pas
[Musique]
combien y avait-il de
quatre avec un abstinent
21 jours 21.
comment vous sentez-vous le jour 21 trois semaines
oui
comment vous sentez-vous comment vous vous sentez je me sens
bien
vous vous sentez comme une nouvelle personne la vie est tout simplement
incroyable tout le monde  devrait faire ça
pouah
[Musique]
toi